okay hey everyone dogan here so after
releasing the most recent video on the
verb rule
a bunch of people ended up asking kind
of the same three questions i'd like to
take a little bit of time today to
answer those kind of three common
questions and i'm going to try and do
this without any cuts this is just going
to kind of be an impromptu japanese
pronunciation pitch accent lecture and i
hope that it potentially hopes uh helps
some people okay so the number one
question that i got was
okay dogan
in this most recent video you said that
verbs verbs specifically
in japanese that end with
always have an accent and that this
accent always occurs on the second to
last beat of the word and an example of
this would be the word to grow up
it has an accent and the accent again is
occurring on the second to last beat of
the word the accent is occurring on the
sound before the tsu
right
so
kind of the actual question was then
i understand that this happens for verbs
but i feel like i'm hearing the same
thing occur in
all words in japanese that end with
i feel like i'm hearing the same thing
occur for nouns as well
nouns that end with
i feel like all of them have an accent
and that that accent is occurring
before the
is this true or am i just kind of
hearing things and the short answer to
this is this is not true and it's kind
of a case-by-case basis thing but the
very important thing that i'd like to
stress here is that the
verb rule this is for verbs specifically
and i think what ended up happening
why so many people
said i feel like i'm hearing the same
thing occur in nouns i feel like this is
a perfect example of your ears playing
tricks on you
if you're still kind of learning pitch
accent it's easy if you're a native
english speaker to hear
utz
and kind of what happens then
unconsciously is
you might see the word for shoes or you
might even hear a japanese speaker say
this word
and when you hear them say it and again
if you haven't really trained your mind
to pick up on the pattern
then even though they'll say it one way
you'll almost
you will quite literally hear them
it'll come into your mind and kind of
your mind will play a trick on you and
you'll hear it being said a different
way so what ends up happening is you'll
think that a japanese person said
and you'll end up saying it that way
even though what they're actually saying
is
so low high low rather than
which is correct rather than
high low low
this pattern in japanese in which
the accent comes at the very end of the
word this is known as the odaka
word final accent pattern
and this i i believe to be the most
difficult pattern for native english
speakers to pick up on and reproduce
this is
why
so many native english speakers and
again i'm not trying
this this is don't be embarrassed to
make this mistake i made this same
mistake so many times and it's
understandable to make this mistake but
when you start learning japanese and you
learn the word for
little brother or little sister
it's spelled like this
right a little sister is spelled like
this
and the overwhelming majority of native
english speakers myself included again
when they start learning japanese
they'll say this as imo
rather than imo toga
because if you're a native english
speaker it's really really hard
to say an accent pattern in which the
accent occurs at the very end of the
word there the same kind of thing just
doesn't really exist in english and so
we're essentially trying to fit
a circle into a square hole if that's
the correct expression it's kind of a a
situation of okay does not compute i'm
just going to end up saying it this way
all this is happening unconsciously this
is why people say
kutsuga rather than
this is why people say imo toga rather
than imo toga this is why people say
rather than
and this is why people say
natsugar rather than not
and so again to go back to the question
if you think that you're hearing people
saying the word like shoes as klutzga
that's almost certainly because it's
easy for you to hear people japanese
people say it's easier for you to pick
up on the pattern in
etc
and then you're kind of unconsciously
assuming that that's happening in other
words that don't belong to the same
family it's dangerous to connect the
dots in ways that should not be
connected it's dangerous to assume that
all words in japanese that end with
must follow this rule as well because
there are instances in which it probably
does happen but it's not a definite rule
so
hopefully that answers that first
question now i don't like to be like a a
salesman and
you know plug my product all the time
but
probably the second most common question
that i got
because maybe only 50 of the people
ended up watching until the end of the
video was
okay how do i learn more about this
paycheck something um is there like a
really good book for this and there are
a bunch of good books for this but in my
personal experience
you either need a
quite high level of japanese to begin
with or
a relatively high understanding of
linguistics in order to
really get
the most bang for your buck from one of
these books
and so what i try and do is i try and
teach pitch accent on my patreon so if
you're interested in learning
more about pitch accent
and you're maybe just beginning your
japanese studies you don't know too much
i tried to create a resource that i
wanted when i was studying japanese
because i got a bunch of these books
when i was studying japanese to try and
learn pitch accent but i couldn't
understand what they were saying because
either they were all written in japanese
or again they were kind of more for like
grad students or
or again for like linguistic students so
i tried to create a resource that
teaches pitch accent to absolute
beginners in very simple clear easy to
understand english and i think it's a
good product and again if you're
interested in sounding as native as
possible i would encourage you to go
check it out at the link below
patreon.com that's the shameless plug
but i am proud of the product that i
created and i do think that it's
probably the best resource out there for
learning pitch accent for cheap i'll
stop talking about my product right now
and move on to the next question and the
next question is
often times when i'm speaking japanese
to a japanese person they don't
understand what i'm saying and this is
frustrating for me because i don't know
where i'm making a mistake i don't know
if if this is a pitch accident mistake
or if i'm making a pronunciation mistake
i don't know why they can't understand
what i'm saying
however in your video you said that
even if your pitch accident is wrong
people will understand what you're
saying so what's going on why can't
japanese people understand what i'm
saying
this is a great question oftentimes
what's happening here is
again in in japanese language classrooms
it's often taught that japanese
pronunciation is quite simple and
because of this japanese pronunciation
is kind of usually only taught at like a
surface level i only learned japanese
pronunciation at a very surface level
when i was taking a japanese course at
my university
and i never learned anything about pitch
accent in that course i had to kind of
do research on my own to learn more
about this and because of this
what happens is you end up developing
bad habits and this results in
many minor mistakes in your speech so
again if you say
um
rather than
people will understand what you're
saying and again this is kind of similar
to saying the word
tomorrow as tomorrow
it's it people will understand what
you're saying but it's a little bit off
however
both of these were saying just these
words in isolation and if we say
many words in a row and multiple and
many of these words have the incorrect
pitch accent pattern it becomes
excessive it becomes
exponentially more difficult for the
native english speaker to understand
what you're saying without additional
effort so if you say this word with the
the incorrect pitch accent and this word
with the correct pitch accent but a
pronunciation error and then maybe you
say this word with an incorrect pitch
accent pattern and an incorrect and a
pronunciation mistake
then that's kind of
you know it's not it's no longer an
issue of some a single word in isolation
it's kind of a series of mistakes a
chain of mistakes and
that's just more and more and more
difficult to to pick up on and follow
you may be making
more pitch accent and pronunciation
mistakes than you realize but
probably you'll be able to iron out most
of these over time and if you want to do
that not over time but
sooner than later then it's good to
study pitch accent and pronunciation
sooner than later i believe okay and the
final question was
about these pitch accent graphics some
people said
well you say that it should be said as
flat you say that this word to open
should be set in a more or less flat
pattern however
there's a rise from low to high in this
graphic so you're saying that it's flat
but it's actually not flat in the
graphic what's going on here this is a
very very very very complicated topic
but to kind of summarize things very
briefly
what happens is
there are different pitch accent
patterns that exist in japanese and one
of them is known as kind of the
accentless pattern in this pattern there
is no accent and at normal speed
normal speed which is quite fast
actually
when a native speaker says a japanese
word that has this pattern they'll say
it in a more or less flat pattern again
as in and i'm just going to say it i'm
not going to put a graphic on the screen
as in
however if you ask a native speaker to
say the same pattern
slowly
carefully in isolation
often oftentimes is it's typically said
with a slight rise in pitch so
it it
it starts low and kind of ah
you can kind of think of this as
something similar to
if i said this english word quickly i
would say
little right however if i said this slow
and in isolation i would say it as
little
right the t's in the middle are
pronounced as a t little but if i say it
quickly then the t's in the middle are
said as a d
little
actually an alveolar tap which is
funnily enough the r sound in japanese
so again sometimes what happens is when
you say a word slowly and carefully
versus at normal speed it's actually
pronounced
slightly differently it's typically best
to show the word this way because there
are other rules
other japanese pitch accent rules very
fundamental japanese pitch accent rules
that kind of rely
on
on the word being taught with this lower
pronunciation and so that's why the
graphic looks like this
and here's here's a native recording of
that same word set at kind of the slow
speed and at the normal speed
the last thing is that a lot of people
asked about these native recordings they
said where do you get these and um i
hire a professional a trained native
speaker who went to the nhk academy
to create these recordings for me and
they've got a great mic so that's where
those come from they're not computer
generated or something like that so
that's the answer to that okay so i
gotta get going but hopefully this video
was useful best of luck with your future
japanese studies and i'll see you guys
again soon
you